you're talking about when I started I
was cutting up cards at Kinkos and you
know flyers and putting them in you know
going to the mall parking lots and
putting him in windshields you know I
mean renting out theaters and do you
think you'd do that now like let's say
there's a young Jo koy out there in LA
right now if we still do it I still do
music Tom cutting up things but you know
like I'm still making flyers to this day
I I mean I just made 10,000 flyers for
my Netflix no you just like the litter
because you don't need it yeah you yeah
you do yeah everyone needs a yeah
everyone comfy a few I mean you know me
your business man like people like
tangible [ __ ] you're still at a group of
people that like to hand they love to
physically grab something from you just
to say I got this you know we look just
uh you remember when they took the CD
away and said it's all streaming now
like you don't go to them you don't it's
not the same anymore the same like I
loved the package I love to opening it I
loved reading the new and every don't
exist there's people after that still
love it and there's young kids that want
to feel that you know I mean and and I
don't know why I do if you enough what
do you do this is Amanda I didn't even
thought this I make I mean you make I
just made 20,000 flyers I get them
printed I don't have to go to Kinko's
anywhere to cut it up you like on but I
get it on the good cardstock I make sure
that it's matte so I can sign it with a
silver pen so I do you sign them at your
shows sign them at my shows I put them
on the tables bro just because your fans
know that you have a Netflix special
there's people in your office right now
that have no idea that I have a Netflix
special and that's the person I want to
reach it's still there you know I mean
not everybody knows like I like my whole
my whole thought process with my with my
career is yeah I'm sold out but I'm
still gonna do radio you're still gonna
do press oh are you kidding me
radio is king to this day it's still
King interesting okay because it just is
like there's still that you know there's
King huh well on a hundred percent
podcast is King but you gotta you still
gotta face it back that there's two
three million people listening to la
radio right now in the morning at least
at least so why aren't you talking to
him
that's life man like you that's your tip
that's your channel so when you do why
wouldn't you go on there and talk about
your podcast that's you that's you
assuming that everybody in Los Angeles
knows about this show that's that's
that's all that's a brave assumption you
want to win well assumption it is it's
bad but you're not dumb no you're not
but you got to understand there's a
reason why big boys still [ __ ]
bad-ass higher there's a reason why Jay
Cruz has a show that's why the woody
show is syndicated that's why Bob and
Tom have like those markets and those
those those shows and those platforms so
this or a reason so when you go into a
city like I'm in Nashville next week
when I go to Nashville that's the new
press and I always go who is it what do
they want me to do oh you should play
every I will play soccer mom Channel I
will go to the pop radio I will do
anything I'll go to a talk show I don't
give a [ __ ] like talk to them dude do me
if they love you if you did that that's
a great relationship to have interesting
like how cool is it to go into a place
and go I'm sold out I'm just here to say
hi like yeah that's cool yeah and they
love you and they appreciate you for
that and I had three shows at the window
sold out six months in advance I my
shows were in June they were sold out
January I still did a full media run in
Vegas as if the show only had two
tickets sold to two and then you push
everything I did every news outlet media
radio everything in Vegas I'm like I did
not have to be there unless them yeah
I'll do that from now on yeah man saying
but I know but you gotta maintain that
and you know and like I said not
everybody knows that you just because
just sold out doesn't mean everybody
knows you're there oh no never leave a
market and they get a tweet going hey
when you come to Nashville it's like now
dude that breaks my heart
yeah but so he goes job when he come to
Indianapolis I think that was it last
weekend and the reason why is because
you thought the pod let him know here's
yeah but if you would have done your
right here's the other thing so when I
was in Indianapolis I did this like in a
radio interview in ESPN blitz a local
like Indianapolis
ESPN station I didn't want to do it I
kept blowing it off my brothers that
came and they really want you to do this
just do it it's like
I I do it the guy was great really you
know a lot of these radio DJ spin to it
forever yeah really good dude I get done
and I get text some club goes whatever
you did [ __ ] move some tickets yeah
my brother text me goes man so many guys
that work would just heard you on the
radio I'm like what that [ __ ] still work
yes I came up with it in a different
kind of like a podcast as king you know
you don't need to do this other stuff
odd cast is king but so is radio know
what I'm saying is it's that that's
another platform that still exists yeah
you're right
and like yeah podcast is king but like
do morning TV is still the [ __ ] yeah
like morning new has it on KTLA are you
kidding me
like you should be on KTLA you should be
like you want to know to hate me you
want to hear this what for KTLA for
promotion my special you didn't do it I
pretended I was sick yes you do that yes
Sam Rubin I should have got a call from
Jo koy yeah min that's to me and that's
in anything you do though to just assume
that everybody knows your business oh I
have I have a I have a billboard up so
everyone should come to my restaurant no
man you need to go out there and tell
everybody you have a restaurant I'm with
you I don't assume everybody I'm not
that naive no I know it's not that big
I'm somewhere my thing is I'm like it's
not my demographic they're older isn't
that what you want you do it yeah you're
right that's the more that that yeah man
you're eating your words right now
that's not my demo what the [ __ ] well
what is your demo your demo is anything
that anyone that likes to laugh there is
no age yeah you're right there is no
race like I sold out a Singapore how the
[ __ ] did that happen well no I'm just
saying and you can too yeah for sure
yeah for sure yeah 100% yeah like that
like you should always look at somebody
and not hate on them but be inspired by
them like yo that dude sold out an arena
I can solid Arena 100% 100
I always use that as inspiration well
let let the haters hate because that's
only gonna feed your fire yeah anyone
that hates it's just gonna be only part
the only person that gets affected by
shouting out hatred or or or throwing
hate year away that they're the only
ones that suffer because they're using
all their energy to promote your product
yeah that's how you got a look at [ __ ]
don't ever think of like yo this dude's
hating on me that's gonna affect my
business know what its gonna help your
business why because your step that guy
is giving other people that guy is using
his platform
to give them a chance to figure out
whether or not they hate you and they
got our own assumptions that's all he's
doing he's going hey you guys I hate
that guy
what are your thoughts yeah probably
about 80% of your bike I kind of like
them so thanks for telling me yeah
thanks and then the other 20% is like
y'all with you and those [ __ ] you
don't want anyway Ameri asked you I went
I went hey ham how do you deal with hate
and you just sent me a picture of a race
horse with blinders yeah oh yeah cuz
it's real I always ask people way more
success to me like how do you deal with
like haters and the activity he's he
didn't say anything he's put
seven-figure hope I can race or the
horsemen saket a race horse and the
horse is like [ __ ] wit's line ders
that [ __ ] only has one thing in
front of them the [ __ ] prize yeah in
front of them yep and all your haters
are though are the people sitting in the
stands yeah betting against you yep
horse number five is gonna suck that
look at him look at the legs on the
horse number five but how that's and the
horse storified doesn't even see them
you don't care he doesn't give up you
care about their opinion he's gonna show
them that I'm gonna win and that's you
you're the [ __ ] racehorse with the
blinders on bro yeah and remember
everyone in the stands wishes they were
a [ __ ] racehorse correct different
wants to be there hands down yeah
everyone in that audience wishes they
were onstage that's why they're paying
to come see you correct
hands down you've won already
it doesn't matter like it and that's and
like I always say like I always say this
like it doesn't matter what you do in
life man there's haters in every aspect
of what everything I'm gonna be at your
workplace
imagine golf for sure but imagine Kevin
Durant yeah best basketball player on
Earth may be the most skilled hey you
know I'm biased I'm from Seattle we
drafted that guy like I'm in love and
he's my favorite player yeah and think
about Kevin Durant they got so bad he
created fake burner accounts yeah
to roast people online yeah you didn't
want to deal with it mmm that's crazy I
love that guy yeah I love him I love
that guy
I got a Brooklyn Jersey coming god I
gotta get the brick god man you know
that it's be absolutely you know if
anyone should know you're you're an
athlete yeah one thing I hate is a guy
that's not really an athlete but likes
to talk like like an athlete and like I
don't know what that injury is I just
know that that's that's usually the time
that these these players start to come
down from their reign it's a bad one
it's a bad one Kobe down it took a lot
of players I think with that Kobe was
older when it happened right yeah Kevin
Durant in his prime like he's literally
in his prime and I'm not gonna assume
that Kevin Durant and come back worse
because Kevin Durant yeah
so he's so talented he's so physically
gifted I'm gonna assume he might be the
guy who comes out keep him better like a
D with his knee surgery yeah Adrian
Peterson everyone goes oh that knee yo
other guys were ruined yeah well he came
back stronger yeah even though he was
older he came back strong with
technology and these guys are such
freaks yeah I don't know if you can base
like that you know what Kobe was never
the same
I get that Kobe's older his whole career
was behind him he has twilight years
Kevin Durant in his prime yeah and with
technology now I think he's gonna
because right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]